we have the pleasure of the 13th world
champion one of the most dominant
players in chess history gary casparov
with us gary yesterday there were some
hiccups you had a completely winning
position completely outplayed wesley so
you must have felt bitter about that but
somehow today you righted the ship and
played incredible chess yeah yesterday i
just the the game three i played against
uh shah um the rfc i was under the same
yes this terrible influence of my game
against especially because the moment i
played knight c5 exchanging this
blocking knight on e6 my only thought
was how on earth i could not win the
game what i had to do not to win this
game and it's just it's and then just
not to play e6 which is just amazing two
times in the game i mean i'm not meant
don't mention other things with playing
e6 and when i just left you know this is
this i was thought oh by the way you
could play a6 jungle and told me early
on winning the piece and then michael
told me ah you can play e6 at the at the
very final moment so i understand with
chuck you know i just i yeah it's hard
because again i'm i'm no longer
professional so it's difficult for me to
to come back and also game three you
know just yeah
you know it's tough yeah and um and
today you know i just i thought why i
played some decent chess so yesterday
and uh and i thought yeah i probably
could do well and uh i was quite happy
with the
game against sam was just you know the
demolition looks funny yeah there's just
no weeks quick squares he he kept
attacking and i just you know i i was
very happy you know with this with the
maneuver that i found bishop was
requieted and then b3a4 and then castle
that's you know that's a good game that
could just could go the textbooks um and
then i actually i'm very proud of my
second game against lebron oh yeah that
was really good they won't play
played very very aggressive interesting
chess sacrificing end games great chess
and i had defend defend defend defend
and at the end you know i just found you
know in the time trouble i'm very proud
found rook g2 and then default check
this is the intermediate check yes i'm
not sure by the way you had access
database was this endgame winning i
thought it was a draw it's winning it's
winning yes but but i knew that he yeah
he had about
10 20 seconds 10 seconds left and i had
about two minutes so just which is
amazing i had more time that in in in in
in in this game against leon that he had
and again i
to my surprise i won the second game and
it's not just winning i just won you
know i earned it so okay
the rumors of my chess deaths probably
had been slightly exaggerated yeah and
uh another game three as well how was
the war that i was like this is a war
you know i
i
yeah i wanted just uh yeah i wanted to
win and that's why you know i tried to
avoid f5 because he prepared a five with
exchanges and it's very difficult you
know just when you have two bishops you
know on in the corners position could
easily you know equalize because it's
difficult to control the center because
bishops attack you know and it could end
up you know with exchanges so he
prepared a five and i thought how can i
stop f5 you know because after five
would be a draw and i thought i found a
great you know exchange sacrifice and i
blew up because i i missed d5 and after
d5 i think actually i'm lost i had about
three and a half minutes he had about 13
minutes
and then that's just a new game started
because you know i think he was nearly
winning you know he needed just to kick
my knight from e4 and he just played
queen e7 queen e3 moved his queen on a5
and i think at one point i mean it was
very unclear i think i could instead of
f1 i could have played b4 it was a very
interesting complications and i think
white was not worse but then i you know
he
i gave him credit queen c5 phenomenal
move because after looking forward i
thought i'm already you know i'm much
better but he found queen c5 and i'm
just you know i'm dead meat again and uh
and then it was an i think at that
moment there's a bishop c1 sighting by
the computers
to guard the e3 square
but that's okay that's the to find the
move you know like you had a minute and
a half on the clock wow
that's yes that's why they like queen d2
better than quincy we did queen d2 but
that's that's yeah that's
and what's up the queen d2
and we actually yeah that's what i
planned because
but this is the my idea was rook f7 but
probably probably look afraid is winning
yes and you go rook takes f7 here rook
f8 is winning you also can get away with
queen takes e2 because you do trade the
queens
and
it's yeah it's still
yeah this should be winning yes yes it's
so still yeah look you know this but but
but but mistake was did the look before
i think after before i had decent
position
uh here in this position b4 yeah no no
no no no no no no sorry yes they're here
because this is a critical position so
this is
he has to take on e4 yes
d4 that's what i saw and now d4 and now
i have two options so this is the uh he
has two the queen a6 or knight takes
before and knight takes b4 is knight
takes before rook takes d8
i take and take a before
or d1 check knight c1 that's what i
calculate the knight c1 quintex before
bishop f3
but i
wasn't
unclear i i think this is unclear yeah
now
my my my
another concern was queen a6 instead of
because i had little time left so i
clocked and again rookie for i liked it
so much so because i missed this thing
as the
queen now take take queen a6 now yeah
and uh and i can't play b5 but um and b5
queen b5 knight a knight d4 but i think
i have a queen c4 black is better
even if i take the knight right yeah
bishop d5 that's what i
yeah rook d5 but maybe okay but maybe
it's playable i don't know is it
playable or you have a computer well the
engine says playable we had them off
during the games so we don't actually
know but this one is on right now and it
says that it's plus point four so it's
playable so white for white yeah wow
so that's the mrs beef and then i just i
was completely lost i think it's just
you know
but i could feel that fabi you know uh
he was so nervous and again clocked
you know we started down this this this
position there was exchange down this
that's the i had 55 seconds he had about
three or four minutes and then you know
just he
after a five ninety five i think he was
kicked off one by exchanging and
95 and 97 he didn't have to exchange the
queens and queen before queens e3
all of a sudden you know i said wow
maybe i have a chance and then with two
bishops i'm not final position now
probably i could have tried but
because i had 40 seconds against 12
seconds but i i was i didn't see
actually the how could i try but
probably bishop takes g6 knight g4
bishop's history i had to try uh to to
check whether he could make a draw
because g bonus is is is deadly gary
i was happy with was right now it's two
and a half out of three you were one of
the best performers today lanier
obviously was the best performer with
three wins but yesterday you might have
been a little bit despondent morose
today you seem electrified you see the
fighting spirit like is it is it knowing
that the opening theory is not in your
way at all and it's just about chess
look this is great i feel really great i
didn't even know who i'm playing you
know so i knew that it's yesterday the
first round with dominguez today i knew
that first round would be would be
shanglan i wasn't sure because i didn't
pay attention to the draw so i come here
i play chess i enjoy myself so and and
by the way as i said i and i left there
they did the room i said oh is he's five
leading no dominguez
what because i just didn't follow other
games and it says
back back to to you to my game yesterday
when i played with white was the ming
says okay it's good stuff i started with
one of the weakest players
he's leading though yes yes and uh and
by the way there's a game one yesterday
you know i i think i had slight edge but
then i misplayed it and uh and i was
almost losing and i think i was again
quite proud that i found
miracle's way to save the game against
linear gary the creativity we're seeing
in this these positions
you must be impressed by some of the
moves that were played wesley playing
knight to c3 sam sacrificing uh again i
mean the i mean i'd have six sorry
knight
no first night d5 in the knight f6 the
game against mvl against mvl and and
also sam
knocking out nakamura the way he did mvl
crushing i mean it it's a different kind
of chess it's still chess but it's just
a different flavor we see in these
different positions yeah because you
start you start the game from move
sometimes from move two i mean it's just
move even move one you know this is you
have you know 15 minutes you know you
have you know little teams being you
know brought together and and and it's
just often you don't even guess the
first move so this is you did and and um
uh i'm you know just uh um i i i feel
good because you know we start you know
we started you know investigating and
you don't have much time so it's one you
know one game one round one one new
position some of them are really tough i
think there's the position that we had
in in round um in round five i think
it's it's much better for white after d4
i think both d4 and e4 i think white is
better so that's the some positions are
really tough to play with with black but
most positions you have you have options
you have options yeah so listen you can
you can create things again set so many
combinations at such an early stage when
i played uh the round four against
against sam he just he told me that you
know i played four games and i didn't
even make 100 moves in total
which is yeah that's that's that's
that's what happens because there's so
many so much creativity so somehow we
play like you know the the great
champions of the 19th century so no
opening theory this is really just you
know we sit that we have to sit at the
chess board and start creating at move
you know you know one two three so like
it's five yeah play b three five i
played g4 i'm not sure good it's a good
move a bad move but something something
interesting so there's
and um yeah
i think people enjoy it uh we definitely
enjoyed it gary you talking about the
great champions of the 19th century you
a great champion of the 20th century and
showing that you're still relevant in
the 21st century we totally enjoyed it
any tournament where gary kasparov is
doing well we
yeah you have a enjoy
memory because last time i was doing
well was a long time ago
well let's hope you do well again
tomorrow i'll i'll try again i already
already has one one two games so that's
in the tournament we're looking for more
for a while we're looking for more
thanks so much for joining us good luck
tomorrow bye thank you gary what a